hello everyone producer Pat here David
is out today he had appendicitis and had
to get surgery in the wee hours of the
morning so he is home resting as he
should be but fear not we have an
entirely new show today it's a theme
show on the topic of the environment and
climate change consisting of stories
that we've done over the years so we've
assembled that we've put that together
for you and that's what we're gonna air
today David I'll be back soon feel free
to send him your wishes I'm sure he'll
make a full recovery be back at it in no
time the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
I have some news that might be shocking
to a lot of people in our audience if I
say the number 97% and climate change a
lot of people in our audience know that
that refers to the supposed consensus in
our scientific community that human
actions on our planet are causing
climate change and this is a number
that's very often cited we have a ton of
science around this number we have a ton
of studies that defend this number
there's 97% consensus and I have what
might be very very surprising news for
many people in our audience today which
is that I'm ready to come clean and
admit that the 97% number is flawed it's
just it's not an accurate number I don't
want to call it fake news because that's
giving them a win on the language which
I don't want to do but it's in an
incorrect number and if you're a climate
science denier and you're starting to
feel aroused and titillated by what I'm
saying I want to encourage you to keep
your clothes on just for a second
because it's not that 97% is too high it
actually is drastically low it appears
that the real consensus over recent
history on human influence of our
climate is 99.94% not 97% and this is
based on a new meta-analysis that looked
at more than 50,000 peer-reviewed
climate change articles from 91 to 2015
and it's not 97% consensus it's 99.94%
and even that number might be too low
because if you look at not 91 to 2015
but just like the last few years it
appears to be 99.99 percent consensus
that human activities on our planet are
influencing the climate and one of the
major problems is that belief in the
science is extremely politicized and if
you look at a recent Gallup survey which
asks people basically three questions
are you worried about climate change do
you know that there's a scientific
consensus and do you believe that humans
are causing it Democrats overwhelmingly
believe that those three things are true
right 85 to 90 percent of Democrats are
worried they believe that there is a
science
the consensus and they believe that
humans are influencing the climate on
the other hand only 35 to 42 percent of
Republicans are either aware of or
concerned about or believe that humans
are influencing the climate so this gets
us to what I call informational
incongruity ok I've talked about this
before this this is something that the
audience seems to react very positively
to because it identifies what I think is
a major problem level one is like we
know about an issue we agree that it's
an important issue but we just disagree
on our position is different right so
like abortion abortion is a political
issue we could debate whether it's
resolved or not based on roe v wade but
we have significant disagreement about
what the policy should be on abortion a
level ii disagreement would be we
generally know about the issue but we
disagree how important it is so like
before same-sex marriage went national
as a result of the Supreme Court
decision most people were aware of the
controversy over same-sex marriage but
some people just didn't really care
about it as an issue they didn't think
it was anything we needed to deal with
like listen it's just not legal in some
places and that's good and I don't care
about that level 3 is a lot of people
don't know about the issue
level 3 informational incongruity that's
like Fox News viewers who might have no
idea that there's a major investigation
into what took place between Trump and
Russia we can't even debate the merits
of it we can't even debate the
importance of it because some people
aren't even aware that it is going on
and on climate change that's kind of the
direction that things are going you
don't even have a majority of
Republicans realizing that a scientific
consensus exists so number one I don't
think anyone's gonna be influenced
because the real number is ninety nine
point nine four versus ninety seven
because if you already trusted the 97%
number you're not gonna change your
position because it's now ninety-nine
point nine four and if you weren't aware
of that number or believed that it's
fake anyway you also don't care if it
goes from 97 to 99 so I actually don't
know how we can really get beyond this
and start figuring out what to do about
the climate science issue but the
numbers are stunning and at this point
completely undeniable and I'm curious
whether you've experienced these sort of
Sciences your religion people there's
people who will write into
hey David you're touting science in a
faith-based way the same way that people
tout religion and I have to explain to
people well hold on a second
science has built-in self correction
mechanisms and in fact in science people
are encouraged there are major rewards
for people who can poke holes in what
are the accepted scientific consensus
consensus consensuses I don't know what
the plural is you can win a Nobel Prize
if you debunk the consensus on science
where do you see that in religion you
just don't you just don't but I think
the religion connection is actually
closer to politics because there are
people doing politics as religion and I
think it's bleeding into science because
what you find is like you said there's
die-hard Republicans that as part of
their Republican identity sure are
saying that this science is just it's
bunk it's all a a green conspiracy
that's a political religion it really
has nothing to do with the science the
thing that gives me a lot of hope is
that when you look at the presidential
elections when you talk about hardcore
Republicans year after year after year
it's about 25 percent of us so most of
us don't fall into that category 75% of
us either look at this consensus and go
like yeah it's real or the other people
in the middle that either don't know
don't care a lot of people it's not
really about climate science so one of
the things that I do on my show is
because that's controversial I talk more
about the pollution because the solution
is the same right not burning fossil
fuels yep so there's ways for us to get
to solutions without having to deal with
the political religions I think one of
them is just taking the 25 percent and
be like you're religious about this we
can't really talk I prefer to talk to
the 50 percent that aren't voting that
are in the middle that just don't know
what to do with this whole situation and
then the people that are already sold
the vast majority of it yeah that is
something I talked about which is you
actually don't need to convince the
outliers and the extremists in order to
win elections because we have 50% voter
turnout in this country and president
Trump conceivably could win reelection
based on a combination of low voter
turnout and our electoral vote system
with an approval in there in the 20s
right in the high 20s you can actually
still win a presidential election
because people don't vote
if the vote shoutout to george w bush
yeah if the voter turnout went even just
from roughly fifty to even something
like sixty two percent you completely
marginalized the ability of those
extremists who have these related and
the religions go beyond the sort of
political religion i think is an
interesting term because you see those
dogmatic beliefs around
constitutionalism and constitutional
originalism the idea of the constitution
effectively as a sacred text similar to
the Bible or the Koran or whatever else
you see it with this what I call strict
father morality strict father morality
is the dogmatic idea that I claim to
want to reduce abortion if I am a right
winger and then someone comes to me and
says we know how to do it comprehensive
sex education and ready access to
contraceptives I'm against that if I'm a
right-wing conservative because you are
not actually behaving in the correct way
if you have unprotected I'm sorry
protected sex non-procreative sex you
deserve the consequences almost like a
strict father saying if you do it you
should get pregnant and you should be
forced to carry the baby to a full term
and give birth to it that is a dogmatic
idea fundamentally it's not a pragmatic
idea where we actually know what works
to reduce the number of abortions right
and I think it applies even beyond
climate change there's a lot of these
pseudo religious dogmatic ideas the
other one is the free market right that
exists on the right this this sort of
religious approach to the free market we
uh I don't actually think that just
because we agree to the consensus
doesn't guarantee what the policy should
be and I think that that scares some
people on the right certainly the
reduction in fossil fuel use is sort of
an obvious one but I think that there's
just a lot of people on the right who
are scared to admit that they are aware
of the consensus or just agree with the
consensus because they believe that it
definitely means I don't know no more
SUVs or whatever it is but there's still
a debate to be had over what the policy
should be although I think as you
pointed out the direction that the
policy should go is pretty obvious at
this point it is and I actually I I
don't even agree necessarily the people
on the right are against reducing fossil
fuels not because of all yeah because
when you actually talk to people I mean
there are plenty of hints
derivative reasons why you should switch
to renewable energy absolutely you know
there's people that are for wind in fact
um I'm researching electric cars right
now and one of the people that is
rumored to have saved the tax credits is
Senator Chuck Grassley of Iowa yeah and
you can't get more Republican than him
but he's into wind energy and the
economics of it makes sense sure so I
don't think it's necessarily and just
out in the world there are plenty of
people that I know that are Republicans
but are driving electric cars that do
care about this that know the science
but that's that's one of the problems I
have with just like dividing people in
the left and right because my own father
he's so annoying that I talk about home
but my own dad was a Republican on when
I was growing up he counts himself as a
libertarian now he drives an electric
car he is singing the praises of it he
volunteered at an aquarium for years you
know he's really into environmentalism
people just don't really fit very well
into these boxes and when it comes to
fossil fuels what I'm witnessing is that
our Congress which makes the laws is far
more extreme yeah then most of the
country on most issues that's true and
that also has a lot to do with the
broader issues of how politics are
financed and a lot of other stuff yeah
totally the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com okay let's talk about big
political issues I've been talking for a
while on the show about what I consider
to be the largest and most impactful
issues for the future of Homo sapiens
and for our ability to continue being
political activists macro issues what's
an example campaign finance reform okay
the way that we finance politics and
elections in the United States is a
disaster and whether you care about
education or public health or whatever
campaign finance reform is a massive
massive meta issue health care if people
don't have access to health care if
people are going bankrupt
because of health care expenses if
people are sick and can't get care you
can't be an activist if you're sick or
focused on figuring out how to afford
the care that you need so health care
for everybody massive meta issue voter
disenfranchisement this includes voter
ID voter suppression election fraud all
the stuff we talked about earlier on the
show today related to Carolinas and
North Carolina's ninth district that is
a major meta issue if people need to
vote to make their voices heard but
their votes aren't being counted that's
a real problem
climate change if your city is
underwater if more people than ever are
dying from heat related illness because
of climate change etc etc it's hard to
be an activist for what you believe in
I've also mentioned net neutrality and
media consolidation how we learn about
stuff is mostly through media and the
internet so that's really really
important I've also talked about ranked
choice voting to break the two-party
duopoly the Trump White House has become
extra obsessed with one of those issues
and that's climate change and in fact
they now are going to create a group to
refute the consensus science of climate
change this is an initiative that
started
within the National Security Council and
the plan is they're going to bring in
scientists who are effectively useful
idiots for the climate denier community
they're gonna bring in scientists that
question for example the severity of
climate impacts they're going to bring
in scientists that question the degree
to which humans are contributing to the
climate change reality on our planet and
they're actually being really clever
about how they're going to structure it
legally because initially the plan was
create an actual Federal Advisory
Committee that is this sort of climate
skeptic committee the problem with that
is that it would then fall under the
jurisdiction of what's called the
Federal Advisory Committee Act and what
that does is it puts in place some
ground rules for these committees
including that they have to have certain
open meeting requirements they have
reporting laws about what they're doing
and what's being discussed if you are
trying to create a propaganda group the
last thing you want is open meeting
requirements and mandatory reporting so
instead they're calling it a working
group working groups have none of those
requirements so we are not going to have
any idea what it is that they're doing
and the plan is to handpick people who
are just useful to denying the climate
science they're going to organize them
in a structure where there will be
minimal accountability no reporting
requirements now you might hear me say
this and wonder why do we care about
this Trump had this election integrity
Commission it folded without
accomplishing a damn thing some of those
business panels that Trump set up ended
up imploding very publicly when notable
CEOs including people like Elon Musk
bailed out because they said I can't
work with Donald Trump the difference is
that this ties directly to two really
important narratives for the
administration number one this is an
administration obsessed with pushing
outdated energy like coal Trump has
expressed multiple times he wants to
rehabilitate reinvigorate whatever the
term is
the coal industry a panel like this one
with no sort of adult supervision can
work in very devious ways to push coal
to pushback against auto efficiency
standards to push back against the
development of alternative green and
renewable energies this would have a
real impact potentially number two these
are the types of groups that end up
gathering position papers and bogus
think-tank pieces which later are cited
as evidence that there's actually a
controversy on the issue of climate when
there isn't so this is sort of twofold
danger number one this is a group that
will have almost no oversight because
again they're calling it a working group
rather than a federal committee it will
have direct value to dirty energy okay
this is a group that could directly help
to line the pockets of the dirty energy
purveyors and corporations and in the
longer term it'll also have this kind of
indirect propaganda value so this is
really really bad the goal is create
something that looks like official
disagreement between scientists so that
they can push the narrative that there
is a controversy we've talked about this
false false balance false neutrality
that we sometimes see in media where
despite the reality that more than 99.9%
of climate scientists agree about
climate change you'll see a media
interview with two Talking Heads one
which agrees with the science and one
who disagrees
that's 5050 even though the science is
99.9 to 0.1 this type of working group
is going to allow them to better foment
those ideas of a disagreement within the
scientific community which basically
doesn't exist even the Pentagon now says
climate change is one of the biggest
threats it is a national security issue
to the military even when the military
is evaluating and considering operations
climate change is now a major
consideration in terms of how they're
going to carry forward some of these
operations and tasks around the world
this is a mechanism
to create just a little bit of doubt
just a little bit longer to try to
foment some sort of plausible
deniability around continuing to push
dirty energy continuing to push policy
that is really great from people who
benefit from that dirty energy ignoring
the as of now undeniable red alert
realities of what it is that we are
doing to the planet into our country
very very dangerous
not very much reported on and we are
going to continue making an effort to
tell you about a lot of this less
scandalous less sexy stuff that is often
not being reported at all but is going
to have a huge long-term impact on us on
the next generation and the generation
after that hey David what about carbon
taxes how would you feel about using a
carbon tax to combat climate change okay
I have kind of like opposing views on
this I hesitate to use taxes you know
that's saying if all you have is a
hammer everything looks like a nail I
don't like seeing everything as likely
to be fixed with attacks if I'm going to
advocate for a tax I want to be really
sure about what impact it will have
you're generally opposed to like vais
taxes taxes on alcohol and marijuana in
cigarettes the type of thing I am I
wouldn't put them all under one umbrella
actually so we've had I think is more
nuanced than that but let me give you an
example in a progressive taxation system
we know that a progressive tax at the
very top on money earned by the very
rich which is most likely gonna sit in a
bank account instead of being spent on
stuff or even offshore right
we know that it's better for the economy
because that's not money that would
likely have a high multiplier effect
because the rich people who get a tax
cut on everything they made above two
million dollars it's not money that they
need and it's not money there is likely
to spend so we know that using that
money to fund programs for people who
actually need the money that is
economically stimulative so that's when
you use a tax not as a change
but more with the analogy as a scalpel
right yeah what am I talking about so in
this same way I actually have seen a
number of good studies that say carbon
taxes at the country and big corporate
level are good ways to combat climate
change it might sound crazy right like
you pay to pollute how does that work
that money actually can be used in ways
that will offset as the word suggests
that will offset the pollution that is
created by the polluters and it can get
us a net lower amount of pollution and
thus sort of help to mitigate or prevent
the climate change problem from
worsening as quickly which is depressing
that that's the way we have to think
about it so I am in favor of responsible
and thoughtful carros thoughtful carbon
taxes to combat climate change when
applied in ways that have been
demonstrated to work and this is a key
okay before everybody says on attacks of
a tax-and-spend liberal or whatever is
it's really really not only as a bridge
to a different future the carbon taxes
should be used in the short term to
offset pollution but in the long term to
push companies and countries to get off
of fossil fuels such that it's not even
a tax that we're gonna need in the
future that's that's my view and it's
very specific it's not any tax I'm in
favor of so you've talked about
countries paying this tax or like big
corporations what about when you get to
like small businesses when you scale
that down to smaller businesses even to
individuals yeah that make any sense I
haven't seen anything on that you know
there are already like when you buy an
airline ticket you pay like a fuel
surcharge that's for the cost of fuel I
I don't know that I love the idea of
passing this on to the individual
consumer because ultimately the
individual consumer working as a group
individuals consumer individual
consumers can lobby for change right
they could say we're gonna boycott
companies that aren't switching to
fought to to renewable energy but why is
it their responsibility I think that
it's actually okay to say we've
identified this crisis that we have in
our country and we're going to
put in place these these carbon taxes
and to combat climate change in the
short to medium term
with the medium to long term goal being
to get off of fossil fuels altogether so
here's why where I want to hear from you
if you disagree with me that
thoughtfully applied carbon taxes
actually work let me know if you're just
against it on principle I don't really
care to hear from you that much quite
frankly I know I still will but I really
don't care to if you want to make the
case that there's no way to do the
carbon taxes in a way that works I want
to hear from you because that would be
counted into two studies the night the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today Elizabeth Kolbert who's a writer
for The New Yorker and also author of
the book the sixth extinction which I
read a couple of months ago now I would
say really fascinating book Elizabeth's
and interestingly you know this week we
actually got a reports from biodiversity
international which is saying we are in
the midst of a sixth mass extinction
which is going right along with the
subject matter of the book so for people
who don't know what we're talking about
what were the first five extinctions why
are we already on number six how did you
first sort of come to know of this topic
and start writing about it and
researching the book well the first
question what were the what were the
previous five that goes back a long ways
we're talking about basically the whole
history of multicellular life which is
very roughly speaking a half half a
billion years and during that time the
fossil record just shows us that there
have been five major mass extinctions
the most famous of which is is v the N
Cretaceous extinction which is the event
that did in the dinosaurs and there's a
pretty broad side to the
consensus that that was caused by an
asteroid impact so the idea that were in
the six and so these events are events
that were during which the diversity of
life on planet Earth plunged very
suddenly once again in geological terms
and to say that we're in the sixth so in
each of those events roughly a
three-quarters of the species on earth
were lost and if we are currently and
another one that's obviously a very very
big deal and the reason that many
scientists think we are in the midst of
another one or if we're on the verge or
another one is simply that extinction
rates are extremely high really
astronomically I compared to what's
called the background rate which is just
the rate at would you expect species to
go extinct in sort of the ordinary
course of geological time and the way I
got on this subject is I was interested
in what was being called the amphibian
crisis so a lot of amphibians and
pinions or frogs and toads and
salamanders a lot of enduring
populations around the world were
crashing and people were trying to
figure out why and in the process of
reporting that story investigating that
story I came across this idea that we're
now in the midst of another mass
extinction and that just struck me as
extraordinary that you know I didn't
know about this and it seemed to me that
that everyone ought to know about it and
in the course of researching the book I
mean you mentioned the the amphibian
crisis and that took you to South
America for part of your research we
also interviewed Ken caldera who you
joined near Australia but at the Great
Barrier Reef how long was the entire
process of doing all the research for
this book including all these different
trips that you you participated in well
the whole process took more than forty
or four and a half years I'd say from
sort of conception two to handie and a
manuscript so it's a pretty long process
and it seems that in a number of these
different circumstances you ended up
sort of camping out in relatively
precarious situations were you much of
an outdoor
person before doing this project I mean
how foreign were some of those
environments you found yourself in well
I I mean I certainly have been on a lot
of hiking trips and camping trips but
when you go to some of these places that
are very remote you really need to know
what you're doing and I was really
fortunate and to be able to go at people
who really knew what they were doing
because I would not I have you know
simply found my way and a lot of them
but they were amazing places to get to
you know the Amazonian rainforest and
the cloud forests of Peru and the Great
Barrier Reef and and and just some of
the most spectacular places on earth was
there a particularly shocking moment in
terms of you know as people read through
the book they will they will learn about
the frogs in South America the problems
with coral reefs dead bats right I mean
there's there's sort of different
aspects to this issue that that you
touch on to paint the picture was there
something you personally experienced
that was sort of like the most shocking
moment in terms of what you were
witnessing in person during the process
of researching this book well one of the
sort of interesting paradoxes of
researching a book is that I went to
these amazing places many of them very
remote and then but the point of being
there was was looking for how human
human impacts some of which were very
obvious and some of which were you know
pretty pretty subtle and had to be
teased out through you know chemical
analysis but I think that what did
really one of the most amazing places I
went during this reporting of the book
was the Great Barrier Reef and the
predictions for the future of the Great
Barrier Reef were very dire and actually
since I was there so I guess you could
say this is not in the course of
reporting the book but very shortly
thereafter there have been several major
bleaching events on the reef area so
that's when the water temperatures get
too high and a lot of the crow turns
white and if it if water temperatures
the korells died and if you look you can
go online and find video of people just
taking these small plans like over the
Great Barrier Reef and shooting down and
you see vast expanses of the leaves have
turned white and there's so there's been
several major bleaching events since I
was on the Great Barrier Reef and the
future of the Raider River which I
unfortunately sort of outlined in the
book just based on on modeling and
predictions is starting to really come
true and that's just to as I say just in
a few years that's really really
sobering and pretty horrifying thought
because the Great Barrier Reef which
when I saw it was already you know had
been severely damaged this is was still
a spectacular place full of life
certainly you know human impact is one
of the biggest themes that goes
throughout discussions of the sixth
extinction
can you talk to our audience a little
bit about I mean I think most people
sort of have an understanding of fossil
fuel use and the way that impacts our
planet trash in the oceans is a big deal
deforestation and that's also connected
to your book the sixth extinction what
are some of the other areas here that we
should be thinking about in terms of how
humans on the planet are impacting what
what you write about and what we're
talking about when we talk about the
sixth extinction well I look at I mean
there are there are multiple drivers of
extinction right now you mentioned some
of the big ones the climate is changing
so many many species are are on the move
looking for ways to to sort of follow
the climate that they are used to which
means in many cases moving towards the
poles or moving up elevational gradients
another big issue that's potentially a
very large driver of extinction and I
think one of the big ones that really
hangs over this whole issue though it
does not get the kind of press but
climate change does
is what's known as ocean acidification
and that's sort of the often referred to
or sometimes referred as global horns
equally evil twin and what happens when
we burn fossil fuel as we dump a lot of
co2 into the atmosphere is that very
quickly a lot of that co2 gets absorbed
in the surface waters of the ocean it
dissolves in the ocean and when co2
dissolves in water it forms an acid
carbonic acid it's you drink it you know
if you have a Coke or if you had some
clogs Oh today you drank quranic acids
it's a it's a weak acid but if you if
you add enough of it to the oceans you
change their chemistry and that's what
we're doing and when people when
scientists look back at the fossil
record and they look at moments where
the oceans became worth more acidified
those are often really really bad
moments for for life in general so
that's a very big issue hanging over
planet Earth right now and that one also
seems to be you know from our
conversation with Ken caldera about this
some of the so-called I don't want to
use the word solutions but actions that
could be taken to mitigate other aspects
of climate change would not really help
ocean acidification in other words like
solar engineering in order to deflect
some sunlight to deal with the warming
component would not even touch the co2
in the oceans aspect he talked about you
know sort of like antacids in large
bodies of water but that practically
speaking that doesn't really seem to be
a great idea that seems to be a
particularly tough one yes and I think
that that that is why you know that one
of the scary things about or one of the
many many scary things about you know
this world that we're creating is that
there is the potential to do things that
would help you know us ourselves our
species but that would be really really
devastating for other species many many
other species and I think there's really
a question which is very difficult to
answer in the abstract about whether you
can you know trash marine life's ocean
life and whether human humanity can
really
do that without a severe severe penalty
and disruption to you in life so I I
think people need to be much more aware
of these issues I don't think we have
any of the answers but we're certainly
not we're certainly treading on very
very dangerous into very dangerous
territory the book is the sixth
extinction we've been speaking with the
book's author Elizabeth Kolbert we'll
pause our conversation there and
continue tomorrow we're continuing our
conversation with Elizabeth Kolbert
who's a writer for The New Yorker also
author of the book the sixth extinction
in the first part of the interview we
talked a lot about the sort of facts on
the ground and the research you
participated in in writing the book I'd
like to talk a little bit with you about
sort of the political situation around
climate change and extinction is part of
the problem in your mind that as you
mentioned we have a sixth extinction
apparently happening here very quickly
in geological time which of course for
the scope of a human life is still a
very very long time is that part of why
it can be difficult to really build
consensus and take action on the broader
issue of climate change because when you
have elections every two or four years
limited resources and people wanting to
get reelected the timeline that a lot of
these things are happening on doesn't
really lend itself to the type of
conversations we should be having yes I
think that's definitely part of it but
it doesn't it's not entirely adequate
because there are obviously a lot of
issues that we do deal with that are
multi even multi you know certainly
multi decade and even multi generational
in scope and somehow we have managed to
do them so climate change seems to
present us with almost a uniquely
dangerous situation and many people have
tried to you know come at this for
different reasons why is it that's
something that is really you know
potentially and I I don't think I'm
exaggerating here an existential threat
to humanity but we seem unable to take
really even the first baby steps towards
trying to solve it in fact you have a
lot of people out there and
now occupy the highest offices in
American government who simply deny that
there's a problem now we are so far
beyond the point where you could deny
that there's a problem and I think I
believe that people increasingly see
this just around them they feel it
around them I'm now sitting you know in
New England it's all you know it's in
the high 80s we should have had a frost
by now we're nowhere near that so I
think people see obviously the climate
is changing it's it's no longer very
subtle I'm afraid have you come across
any ideas as to how we might more
effectively communicate with so-called
climate skeptics or deniers of science
we know from the research done by folks
like Daniel Kahneman for example that
just sort of beating people over the
head with facts does not really seem to
be too effective in bringing people over
and sort of predisposing them to want to
take action is there like a patriotic
appeal that could be made maybe a
national security appeal that you've
thought of I mean what what might be a
better approach to try to build
consensus well I think that as you say
the thrust of a lot of social science
research over the last 20 30 years has
been yeah you can give people as much
information practical objective
information as you want and it doesn't
really change their mind once their
identity is sort of tied up we believe
in one thing or another and I think that
many people have concluded therefore and
so we're in this kind of interesting
standoff that you know people you know
people like me the media you know even
politicians on the Left even you know
are not going to or unless you know
center-left whatever are not going to be
the ones who are going to be able to
reach people who is political identities
or cultural identities and are now tied
up with denying that climate change
exists that the messengers are going to
have to change religious figures
generals all of those right-wing
talk-show hosts you know all of those
are
potentially people who could change this
conversation but they had to launch it
change the conversation well what would
make them want to I guess is the
question right that is exactly what
we're waiting for that is what we're
waiting for and I if I had that answer
you know I'd be out there trying to make
it happen that there is this kind of
like inherent optimism that exists in
some people who say we don't need to
worry about this and I'm not talking
about those who say God would never have
set up a planet that we could damage
right I'm not talking about that view
I'm talking very specifically about the
view which is I'm not worried about this
because humans are smart and resourceful
and will always stay slightly ahead of
it actually becoming a crisis how do you
communicate with someone like that and
explain to them that the crisis is now
that we're seeing more you know heat
related deaths among the very young and
elderly than we've seen for a long time
whether of that whatever argument you
can make how can you explain that this
is already sort of outpacing human
ingenuity well I think that what people
really need to appreciate with climate
change and why climate scientists have
really been trying desperately to issue
these warnings is that there's a
tremendous amount of inertia in the
climate system and it's not the case
that you can say and the nursery springs
from a few different directions as it
were first of all they're still warming
in the pipeline so even if we just
really stopped emitting co2 basically
tomorrow which you know evidently we're
not going to do there's still a lot of
warming left in the system until the
climate reaches a new equilibrium and
I'm not going to go into the kind of
geophysics of that but it's pretty basic
science
um and so what you're seeing what you
see out your window the idea that okay
when it gets really bad we'll fix it
that is simply in this case
unfortunately not possible because
you've already set things in motion that
you can't get back this is why
scientists are so worried for example is
the Antarctic West Antarctic ice sheets
starting to disintegrate because once
you set that in motion
there's a lot of inertia in that system
and you're not going to get that back so
that's one reason why we really need to
be proactive as opposed to reactive
another reason is obviously just that
energy systems take a long time to
convert you know it's very very
difficult to our whole economy the
entire world economy basically for all
intents and purposes right now runs on
fossil fuels if you want to change that
which evidently we have to you've got to
get going and you've got to get started
and you can't expect it to happen
tomorrow so there's a lot of inertia in
that system as well and when you sort of
you know add together all these forms of
inertia you realize that we really
needed to start this process a long long
time ago is there anything you're seeing
that makes you at all optimistic and it
could be either at the you know micro
level at a more macro level it could be
you know changes we're seeing in China
or India that are slowly moving away
from fossil fuels is the soul sort of
provider of energy even though it's
happening relatively slowly something
that you know a private company like
Tesla is doing we've had seven or eight
countries in Europe that have said over
the next 10 or 20 years they want to get
all fossil fuel using vehicles off the
roads I mean it all sort of feels like
they're not really the strongest
commitments they could be changed if it
ends up not being that convenient and
even still it's it might end up being
sort of too little too late I mean is
there something to be optimistic about
well I think that those are the wrong
you know those are sort of the wrong
categories that we keep looking for some
I think one of the other problems that
we have in dealing with climate changes
that we keep looking for some answer
there's going to be one answer that's
going to sort of silver bullet and it's
just not that kind of a problem you're
going to need a million different
answers but I do think the one hopeful
development I suppose you could say is
you know the really really radical
decline in the price of solar power so
that there are now times of day in
certain parts of the country some parts
of the world where you know days you're
giving away
power and once that happens there's a
lot of things you know that you can do
with that power that might be really
useful like you know charge your
electric car and things like that so I
think that that is a very positive
development and one thing that it's show
is if you talk to it
experts is that you know that didn't
just happen that happened because there
were a lot of entities including you
know the Chinese government and the
German government which put a lot of
money into solar power and what's known
as feed-in tariffs where you basically
utilities had to buy solar power all
these things you know then I won't get
into the too bogged down in that
bureaucratic details but a lot of lot of
effort on the part of a lot of Governors
governments and also entrepreneurs went
into this and we need that on many many
different fronts so that unfortunately
brings us back to the current
administration which is actually you
know the budget just slashed our MDE on
a lot of these programs which is
obviously exactly a long way to go yeah
I mean along those lines at face value
at the 30,000 foot level it seems well
one thing that should happen is
government should stop subsidizing oil
in the production of gasoline and
instead put those subsidies towards
renewable energy is it that simple would
that make a big difference that would
make a huge difference I think people
don't really appreciate it you know how
many tax once again we don't we don't
see them unless you're in that no oil
industry the coal industry you don't
know where the tax breaks are but
they're huge and people have compiled
them and those amounts to government
subsidies and when you compile them
they're in the you know I can't remember
them you know hundreds of billions of
dollars it's or I don't remember what
the figures are but they're very very
high and if we took all that you know
that pot of money which is basically a
pot of missing revenues and we put it
toward you know you took it away from
things that we don't want and put it
towards things that we do want I don't
want to say it would solve the problem
but it would go it would be a huge step
in the right direction less food that
way we've been speaking with Elizabeth
Kolbert she writes for The New Yorker
also author of the book the sixth
extinct
which I recommend highly to the audience
Elizabeth thank you so much for talking
to us about this thanks for having me
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
hey David what policies actually make
the most sense to deal with climate
change this is a really good question
particularly in the context of the g20
summit and the United States being the
only of 20 countries that didn't sign on
to the sort of climate change agreement
or intent to work on the issue of
climate change I think to answer the
question properly you really need to
divide it up into short term versus long
term action on climate change we need
some short-term ideas on climate change
to serve as like a bridge or a funnel to
the long term solution that we
ultimately want so number one we need to
understand what causes emissions
emissions are a big part of what we're
trying to ameliorate energy causes huge
emissions transportation causes huge
emissions animal agriculture significant
contributor to emissions manufacturing
of stuff a massive contributor to world
emissions so let's address some of those
with our ideas number one in the short
term carbon taxes okay carbon taxes make
sense in the short term there is some
disagreement among the left as to
whether we want revenue-neutral carbon
taxes or carbon taxes that will raise
revenue which can then be used for
whatever right insert here in either
case study after study has demonstrated
that carbon taxes will incentivize
cleaner manufacturing and cleaner
transportation period number two we
should have targets for X percent
renewables by Y date in the future
sometimes the targets are unrealistic
it'd be great to have realistic but
aggressive targets in either case we
need to be setting goal posts and trying
to reach those goals number three we
should reduce the amount of meat that we
eat there's really no way around that at
this point moving to lab-grown meat is
definitely a possibility that might be
more palatable to people who eat a lot
of meat I am down to eating red meat
probably five times a year
and
poultry I don't know maybe once every
ten days and beyond that I am
pescetarian for most of the time we know
that this is a good thing
and until lab-grown meat becomes a full
reality we should be doing that and then
we've got to incentivize renewable
energy like yesterday I mean right away
right now we are subsidizing a lot of
the wrong forms of energy fossil fuels
oil Trump talks about clean coal trying
to revitalize an industry that the free
market has clearly shown should be dying
coal should be going away completely we
do want to incentivize the generation of
renewable energy stop incentivizing the
continued harvesting of fossil fuels and
and this is a controversial part I've
gone back and forth on this over the
last many years I'm open to open to
using nuclear as a bridge to get off of
fossil fuels and to renewables but
number one takes a long time to get new
renewable on board I actually don't know
that at this point the timing even makes
sense like I'm conceptually open to
nuclear as a bridge but given how long
it takes to actually start producing new
nuclear power I don't even know that the
timeline makes sense for us
geopolitically this is all really
important stuff if we reduce our demand
for fossil fuels this weakens the
leverage that country's hostile to us
have a Venezuela Russia I'm not saying
we should never try to have good
relationships with these countries I'm
merely saying that deleveraging them
when it comes to manipulation and
control over the oil markets would be a
very good thing
geopolitically and a very good thing in
terms of national security yes there may
be short-term pains in terms of gas
taxes or other costs that would be part
of a long term solution but I think that
if we think through it carefully the
government can ensure the
that those who would be most hurt by a
slight uptick in the cost of gas or
other fuel energy sources we can
mitigate those impacts and I think that
we should if I'm missing something here
send me your thoughts I want to hear
from you new homes have had the option
of building with solar power for a long
time in the United States and the cost
of doing so has come down over time but
California is going to make solar power
a standard requirement on all new homes
built in their state and the day after
tomorrow the California Energy
Commission will be voting on new energy
standards for new homes and they're
expected to mandate solar panels on
homes built starting in 2020 so this all
sounds great except that there are two
camps that oppose this both on the left
and on the right so you've got the right
wing anti-regulation types who say they
just don't want more regulation and the
government telling people how they have
to build homes of course there's always
been regulation or at least for a long
time on new homes whether it's
insulation standards or heating
efficiency standards whatever this is
just the evolution of those standards I
don't think that's a very good argument
but there are also people sort of on the
Left who wanted a net zero requirement
they wanted Net Zero to be the standard
meaning that the house has to produce
more solar power than it uses not hugely
realistic because right now our ability
to store solar energy is pretty limited
so at night when the Sun is down homes
even with normal solar installations
need to pull electricity from the grid
so the decision was made that's a little
too much right now let's mandate some
solar of course there will be some
exceptions and that's almost always the
case here and the important thing to
remember is yeah even if really rich
people building mansions are going to
potentially be able to get exceptions or
some large commercial office buildings
or I'm sorry not commercial leased
buildings least residential buildings
we'll be able to get exemptions overall
this is a move in the right direction
and like with any market that has new
regulation people will be able to get
around it some people will but the big
picture is a really really good one
and I think that there's another
interesting element here that people
often like to point out which is
okay fine you put the solar panels on
and the energy is solar but you need
fossil fuels to make the solar panels
and you've got all these solar
installers driving around burning
gasoline even if they have electric cars
that they're driving around in the
electricity comes from fossil fuels
we've dealt with that argument many
times before that needs to be figured
out and it eventually will be but in the
short term let's at least make the move
to solar power and then we'll continue
to work on reducing the carbon footprint
and the fossil fuel footprint of the
creation and installation of the solar
panels like that that's one of those
examples where people say well there's
still fossil fuels in the system for
doing solar panel installation yes there
is but you're taking a step up the chain
towards renewability and sustainability
we that argument was made on the show
ten years ago it made no sense then and
it makes no sense now the real concern I
have is that real estate prices are so
out of control in California especially
in the area in and around San Francisco
Los Angeles as well that anything you do
that will initially make it more
expensive to build a house is going to
make real estate even more expensive and
I don't actually have the answer to that
even though in the long term having
solar saves you money on heating
anything that's gonna push prices up in
California even further is something I
would be very very concerned about and
I've not yet heard a good explanation as
to why I shouldn't worry about that if
you have an answer let me know we've got
a great bonus show for you today I don't
have time to tell you what's on it I
don't have time to play a voicemail for
you but the bonus show will be great
today and I hope you'll join me that we
have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine two david p this kind of
bummed me out i've been getting a lot of
emails and voicemails like this here's a
caller in despair over climate change
take a listen
hey david i call today because i just
wanted to know if there was a way for
the youth particularly myself and teen
and college students in particular to
get over feelings of hopelessness in
regards to climate change under trump's
america because by the time a lot of us
are old enough to run it'll be too late
to really do anything substantial thank
you well the show have a good day
I get it I mean it's that we everyday
that we don't work towards a solution on
climate change is now two days we need
to undo worth of damage if that makes
sense so I really don't know what to say
I share your despair and of course we've
got a vote we've got to vote them out
the Republican Party is not just the
only party in the United States
prominent party that rejects the science
on climate change it's the only
prominent party in any western country
that rejects the reality of climate
change and I would even argue in
developing nations you don't really have
serious prominent parties that say now
we just don't believe it it's a hoax so
I wish I didn't share your despair but I
do and beyond voting and encouraging
states and municipalities and cities to
do what they can we've got to vote them
out and we are running out of time
that's just the reality I'm also out of
time to tell you what's on today's bonus
show but it's a good one become a member
become a patron for at least five bucks
a month we will speak to you then the
show doesn't have to end right now
because there is a bonus show every day
for our supporters and I hope to speak
to you that
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]